i probably feel like i get a little i do
get a little bit frustrated at the um
how much injuries are talked about
for for me and i realized that i've had
two major surgeries in the last three
years so that's that's justified but
um
i can't do like an interview these days
or something without someone saying oh
the injuries of this or that yeah
mate i've actually
played live at 200 games in the last 10
years so it's about 20 20 a season i
must be on the field a reasonable amount
of time but um
sort of being stuck with a tag you know
um
i've got to try to shake that
oh um i've never been into this season
other than just a little um
mcl tweak which is you know i was out
for two weeks so you wouldn't really
it's just a niggle yeah
but it doesn't
change things um
yeah the neck the neck was um
filthy with benjamin oh
i had one the other day and they just
saw no one's had to cut themselves up
off the ground more than you you know
the amount of injuries you've had lost
hold up material
yeah i think you're right um that one
was just a really unfortunate exit it
was an accident really there's timing um
just so many things that
you know and and rare i went into
to clean a guy out i sort of lined him
up early
thought up i'm going hard here and just
as i had um
i think it was ryan crotty he'd cleaned
him from the other side so it just
changed the position of his hip
and i was targeting sort of his rib area
and as a result my head went straight
into into his hip bone and i just felt
like a crunch
i lay there i thought i was um just a
bit dazed
but concussed and knocked out
um
and then
i just had a massive intense pins and
needles all down my right arm
and but i've had stingers before but it
was worse than that yeah but it did it
did go away
um
and then i remember seeing the
other doctors were there and i remember
seeing bodhi there and um the they'd
bring out that little golf cart thing to
put me on
and i was like now there's no way
it's not that bad i know what's happened
i'm i'm just i'm knocked out so i asked
him to pull me up and he pulled me up
and then um we were walked off i saw you
when i was walking off man i feel pretty
ginger here
and we went out the back of the stadium
they wanted to put me on some gas i said
oh it's actually it's not actually
i don't know it's not too bad
i think and they said oh we want to take
your hospital asking
man this is annoying
um but i said so much adrenaline and
just like the in fact i've been i was
warm and on the field because by the
time i got in the ambulance and we're on
the way to hospital man the pain started
to kick in big time
yeah yeah and um
but not at any point did you think oh
i've fractured my neck
because no one knows what that feels
like really unless you picture it
wanting to know how the boys were
getting on in the game it was a tight
game
but then once we got to hospital you
know i was sitting up um i had to go in
for a s x-ray i was lying down
a lot of pain
swing myself back up and lie on the
beard hit my phone
um
and then next minute they
doctors and nurses rush in and put a
brace around me and start running their
hands over my feet can you feel this can
you feel that
far out what's going on now and that was
the moment they they said oh you've
uh broken your neck and and
your vertebrae in two places um it's a
fracture dislocation actually so
actually vertebrae's like your yeah each
vertebrae is like a
round circle almost um broken it in two
places and that that pieces is
dislocated forward uh
yeah but they said you're gonna oh
people ask if i was if i was scared or
like but because at no point i couldn't
feel my legs or feet or anything
and then i was already in their care
at no point did i sort of feel like i
was gonna go backwards from where i was
so i didn't really have that
massive fear of am i not going to be
able to walk or
anything like that i did just have the
the worry in the back of my head that i
wasn't going to be able to play rugby
again but in that moment it didn't seem
that important
either
considering the injury yeah
and is it true that you were by only
your really strong neck which you do
have a massively strong mat saved your
saved your
saved you from stop um not being able to
walk
yeah it is it is um and there was a
so the surgeon
um showed me two x-rays this was after
surgery
one was mine and one was a 15 year old
south african boy and they're almost
identical
um and that that
poor fella um he's in a wheelchair now
the rest of his life uh and the the
difference was that i'd all the sort of
built up muscle and strength around my
neck and upper back
so when
my body almost went as a shock and all
those muscles just spasmed up and
stopped that that fracture that
dislocation piece
from going any further or moving around
and damaging my spinal cord so
um yeah that was a bit of a sobering
moment i think and a realization of how
lucky
i was or how close i could have been to
to
been just like that that 15 year old
south african boy
that's crazy
that is crazy and it makes you
straight away made me appreciate him and
thankful for all the the nick and
strength work that uh
the trainers get you doing yeah had you
done extra you like you you do have a
very strong big thick neck
have you done extra neck work from a
young age or is this all part of the hay
bale routine
it's like like body's six speed program
six weeks
no honestly i think it's just one of
those um
things that i
almost genuinely um
i wouldn't at all i wouldn't have said
it was a genetic gift up until um
he had an injury because i used to get
so much [ __ ] from the boys about it and
then
whenever we have outfitting
getting your number one if it is i'd be
like you're about to be about an excel
and i said no no try through exhale so
it's like swimming on me it just fits my
neck and i have to move the button a bit
further
and taper in the hot the rest of the
shirt
um but yeah it turns out to be a bit of
a blessing and yeah i don't do
i didn't do any more next work than
anyone else leading up to the injury um
and i'll probably only do a little bit
more now
that guilty mate you don't need to
overdo it like your neck was strong
beforehand and that's what saved you you
don't need to you know be gone
all out just keep doing what you're
doing so i keep ticking away at it but
we did an extreme testing the other day
and it's um you know up there with with
the props neck strength so i think it's
just one of those things no yeah i'm
lucky
and then when you're coming back from a
fractured neck like how hard is this one
this is the one that must be once you
like once you feel like it's recovered
how do you go about being able to play
throw your body into contact knowing
that what you've been through
if i'm honest i think like i had my
shoulder surgery last year i found the
shoulder
rehab process more difficult than my
neck one for different reasons um but
my shoulder surgery was a pretty it was
a major um
i didn't end up having four operations
sort of tied into one but just the
small rehab work and the
almost micro gains that will sometimes
feel like i wasn't making any gains by
the end of the week and
chipping away at that compared to my
neck because it was a bone
it just needed time to heal
but the biggest hurdle i had to overcome
was just the the mental one of getting
back and playing
yeah after
so i was
three months in the neck brace
um where i couldn't do anything i wasn't
told i was told not to lift anything
more than three kilos so this time i've
been so
sort of almost precious with my body and
so i've become so fragile and with
things uh just had to work more build my
way back up to
throwing myself around like i remember
the first time i got the old clearance
from the surgeon and i can get back into
rugby training
physio's live we just want you to be on
your knees and then fall to the ground
and it's like oh
and that was such a mental hurdle for
myself because
i've just been looking after it so well
yeah i was like well i'll be all right
yeah and then there's just all these
little hurdles from there of
you know once i've done that and you
know and it's all in your mind you know
once i've done that oh i'm okay doing
that maybe i'm okay doing this but each
time it's it's it doesn't feel any
easier than the next step or the last
step yeah and right up until the point
that you're attacking it um
i've got um tomboy matson to thank for
all the he spent um hours with me
working on my he was our defense coach
at the chest at the time
up on the mats um doing tackle practice
with him to the point that i was really
confident
and i was confident going into my first
game i was off the bench versus the
blues and
got on earlier than i'd anticipated
because there's a couple injuries um
but i got out there and i wasn't that
confident man i was like running around
i couldn't help but think about it going
into collisions
and i
when i watch the game you can't tell
that i'm hesitant but in my mind i was
hesitant yeah and then
i thought after that man this is going
to take maybe a bit longer a bit harder
than i thought i've always had the
attitude after an injury like if you're
going to play you just got to rip in
like you've just got to go hard from the
outset and not
not think about it because yeah
but i couldn't help but think about it
it was weird i never had that issue
before
the next week i got named to start
and so i just had the same attitude like
i've just got to rip in and um
i don't know why exactly but i got over
at that second game straight away she
wasn't in my head yeah and then
every now and then i'll find myself in a
similar clean out position
um
and it's almost i don't know i must be
like a
a line in my
memory path path to my brain traumatic
one of knowing what they've been in this
position before and it's no good but
yeah i'm also a little bit better around
self-preservation um i think
i
can cast a few times earlier in my
career because i just goes hard into
things and try and like dominate every
collision or just trying
whenever every moment i could and now
because i've had to i just
have um
tried to pick moments a little bit
better you know
you have just smoke every round i
remember
it's a short line out against aussie
david pocock 10 meters back i'm 10
meters back i knew he was getting the
ball i just sprinted as hard as i could
and tried to smoke him
and he's just that he's a ball of muscle
and i collected his hip and then i was
cast
one of my coaches sat me down he goes
look at this collision do you really
think you're gonna
this is a good one to try and win
you just gotta make the tackle here you
don't have to send them
try and send them backwards and i was
like
again it was the moment that's like it
makes a lot of sense here got to start
trying trying to play a bit smarter
that's fascinating fascinating hearing
the
the mind battle coming back from andrea
yeah i mean you obviously throw your
body and you have to throw your body
into contact you definitely have a
reckless regard for your body when you
watch your place so
to have that mindset is so important for
you to be able to perform i guess
yeah it's
exactly like i've sort of thought that
that's how i play that's
how i play well
and it comes with that high risk but and
i wasn't sure if i'd be able to sort of
make those decisions in game yeah
and but i have i have learnt to
yeah luckily
hopefully it can if you can take another
three four five years onto my career